taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the mic I'm talking taste buds hey
folks welcome to t-a-s-t-e buds
flying solo again today without Sal
vulcano he's taking care of business
don't you worry about it he'll be back
soon enough but for now it's just me and
my phone
Dan Soder guest hosting with us today I
I could in my insecure brain work up a
scenario to think that Sal had a problem
with me
now I called he's had a multitude of
podcasts that I've never been on and I
finally get on taste buds and it's you
that invite me he's only had two three
podcasts one of them that none of I mean
one of them was popular with q but no
none of us knew he had it oh I didn't
even know that one honestly I didn't
even know he had that one none of us did
then he's got this one and he's got the
one with Chris yeah
uh I've only been on I can't get spit
out of the one with uh I've only been on
hey babe when Sal was absent
that's what I mean dude yeah so you know
Sal is the nicest guy in the world Until
you realize he's a bond villain we
talked about it on the last podcast he
couches everything in niceties
but there's really something else going
on I think there's real heat between Sal
and I yeah exactly
there's heat dude the uh uh I think
because he knows I think he knows what
the take I'm coming in here with and
anything you want to be around here for
it
he uh well he he when he when he when I
knew he was going to be here you were
the first guy I called because we've
been trying to get you on because he
knew he was going to be here
he's not going to be here so I knew
immediately yeah you know call you up
exactly so yeah so here we are I've been
waiting I love this podcast thank you as
a pothead
this podcast is built for me it's all
you could ever have wanted yeah I want
I've always wanted I've always wanted
food Wars
I I love it it is uh more stressful than
you'd think it would be sometimes with
the research the tasting research I
don't do any research but I just uh it's
just the argument it gets heated it gets
hot it gets hot sometimes I could easily
number one I know you right and I know
Sal
and I know that how much you care about
food
surprised at how many weed enthusiasts
like yourself
uh enjoy the show because I would always
think that like
I I haven't been a weed smoker in many
years but I would feel like oh my God
all the yelling would be like too much
no because you're it's it's fun yelling
it's not like it's not a combative it's
like a peaceful energy yeah you know
you're like you guys are peacefully
yelling about yeah we're not just we're
not talking about scotus yeah you're not
getting into stuff there's too much
yelling there's already enough yelling
outside but I'm fine with that I'm fine
with yelling if it's about food or
wrestling right I wish you could tell or
video games yeah yeah uh childlike
things yeah yeah very interesting I'm
starting I'm announcing it again
a solo podcast is going to have its own
channel on YouTube it's on patreon down
down with jodarosa I had a podcast years
ago called down with Joe Rosa that was a
different format this is a new relaunch
of the podcast me Solo movie discussion
discussing all my collectibles
discussing video games discussing food
it's going to be a real show and tell
type of a deal what's your Collectibles
well you know I buy video games I know I
buy a lot of video games I buy a lot of
Blu-rays and box sets and things like
that wow video game systems why Blu-rays
if I can ask you I like owning it dude
but the technology is fleeting it's not
not if you have the technology to play
the technology yeah but then if someone
breaks your house it's gonna look like
an old Radio Shack who's gonna have he's
gonna have a bunch of old good and when
the grid goes down
I'm gonna have all the movie Power yeah
and then you're gonna get killed because
you're gonna need a generator yeah
yeah listen you don't think about you
don't think about when the water wars
hit
you're gonna need a [ __ ] generator
bud and you're not gonna be able to play
with none of your things I'm gonna pedal
my I got my exercise but my Bowflex
right after my PS5 you just go into a
Cadillac all right this is one level of
God of War I can get one objective done
a God of War I'm telling you dude like
I'm never in a pinch man I'm never in a
pinch for what I want to love like and
when I wanna that's great enjoy it it's
there streaming sir I use streaming
services all the time all the time I
love all technology I just love all of
it what about moving
it's not I'm damn I don't have you know
you're talking like I have uh you know
like like Collectibles no but I'm saying
like you have collected you have
multiple Collectibles to me that's
lifestyle statue replicas when Batman
Returns I'm gonna watch it that's like
video games I'm gonna walk in and
there's the animorph of the uh Alien
just a giant you have a predator it's
just I just you know most most of it
fits into a few boxes okay crazy I
thought you were packing it up like
you're packing up a comic book store the
DVDs take up more boxes than you think
they're going to but that's only because
you can't
if you put if you filled large boxes it
would be almost nothing but you can't
fill a large box with that many Blu-Rays
and DVDs because it's too heavy and then
it'll break and that's not fair to
whoever's helping you move do you have
vhs's
very very limited amount at this point
uh that technology is flimsy I have a
VCR hooked up to your TV to an upscaler
it goes through an upscaler can I ask
you a uh can I ask you was last time you
jerked off to VHS porn
College you so you don't have a couple
no floating at your house no why in
God's name would I I mean and I guess to
a porn Enthusiast I now sound like you
do to me but no I uh porn's one thing
that I do not need hard copies of nope
no pun intended
uh but no I don't need hard copies of
porn I need I like listen my favorite
thing to do in the world aside from
complain
is collect media okay which is what this
whole podcast is based around yeah I
will have a section cut segmented off
for me to complain yeah and then I will
have my media stuff and then my food
thing which is my third favorite thing
uh I basically designed the podcast to
be the title meaning like this is what
it's like to be friends with me like
these are the things I if I had a
one-sided friendship this is what it
would be yeah your F1 you know what
though like becoming your friend I knew
which topics that's how friendships
start you learn which topics you share
yeah and you grow on those and then you
bump into other topics that you share in
common and I'll probably drink through
the whole thing just to just to tie it
all together are you gonna put I should
put the complaining at the end
you want to hear the segments yeah let
it rip let's talk about the preview for
down with JoJo yeah let's talk about the
new show on the current show down with
jodarosa segments that I'm going to be
doing a recap show called is Dan down
with Joe DeRosa
in every episode caught it
folks Joe DeRosa here with your live
dates update where am I going to be I'll
tell you where I'm going to be December
8th 9th and 10th I'm going to be in St
Petersburg Florida December 8th is we'll
see you in hell Live December 9th and
10th it's me doing I Never Promised You
a Rose Garden my new show which by the
way we are doing at the crane theater in
New York City on December 14th come on
out for that I'm doing the show again in
Austin Texas January 13th and 14th then
in Levittown at Governors on the 20th
and 21st then again at the crane theater
January 25th in New York New York get
all tickets show times and information
at joederrosainfo.com come check me out
and if you're not getting enough of me
on this podcast swing on over to
patreon.com
w s y i h podcast and you can sign up
for the we'll see you in hellpod where
me and Patty Walsh talk about movies uh
reviews commentary all that stuff stuff
and last but not least of course Joey
Rose is seven days a week opening at 11
30 a.m every day booze and sandwiches
from open till close it's a party people
it's a fun time so many of you have come
through I am so touched at how many fans
have come through to show love and
support it's amazing it's been amazing
we've been open officially now for a
year we made it through the first year
it's it's incredible thank you everybody
thank you come see us all info about
Joey roses plus ordering online
joeyrosesnyc.com
good but I'm down with Joe DeRosa hey so
these are the these are the segments
uh D views
reviews of media toys and other fun
things I buy okay delish okay food
discussion and reviews great
d-pad all video game stuff all right and
then D-Day what's on my mind today
storm this beach dude yeah
and then they'll all be spelled like d e
I love it I didn't even notice it till
now yeah and I was like oh okay I get it
I think that's cool right sure is that
stupid I don't know I don't know how
it's gonna look you can tell me if you
think it's stupid I don't care no I like
I like uh alliterations but I also like
um that's not alliteration yeah I just
realized that now it's play on words you
know when you realize like a d-pad on
the video again yeah and then so I
didn't know you're gonna do d e like
DeRosa yeah because it's kind of funny
and stupid yeah stop for Deepak do it I
don't care it's your podcast yeah but
I'm asking you do you think this is a
stupid idea because you're not you're
reacting in a way that I know you well
enough to think you don't like the the
names I don't like calling it no I don't
why delish bug Academy
the way you said delish just in my back
I was like yeah okay so I shouldn't do
the names of the segments I love the
segments I think the segments are
perfect I'm doing the names of the
segments then don't do the notes why I
don't know it's funny it is funny
it's dildoing yes
and funny pimp what do you think of the
names of these segments for my podcast
uh and keep in mind they're all going to
spell they're all spelled D E and then
the second syllable okay
so D views where I review media and toys
that I buy delish where I talk about
food
d-pad where I talk about video games and
D-Day what's on my mind today d-days
it's very cringe but I like it we need
animations on the bottom of your head
yeah yeah you got to add uh yeah yeah
but it's cringy but it's funny it's
great I love it all right also you
should tell him how uh Al Jackson
described your apartment that's my
favorite I'll just grabbed Al Jackson
describe my apartment as it looked like
I had a 15 year old son that died we
didn't change anything
that's perfect
see what I mean this is a black coffee
yeah
what do you no what do you mean I
usually get cream in half and half by
the way she only had one percent and she
said she was very busy making sandwiches
so competition they make sandwiches over
there
God bless these people they're not we're
not we don't compete we do two different
things oh they pumped all our coffee
they're wonderful people over there the
old black cat coffee shop go see him
when you're in New York
but don't get coffee if you like having
uh half and half or milk in it yeah in
any case because that's you're gonna
watch that just sit there and melt
you're not gonna drink it I don't like
black coffee
what happened to your cream
I tuned out on all that dude I'm sorry
this I missed everything all right but
this is I got coach I got cringe
segments on my uh podcast do you want me
to get milk I'll go get little milk uh
it's fine dude we're fine we're already
locked in a little milk guys I could
have got a Duncan 25 minutes ago I'm
fine I mean the fact that you live in
New York City I like Dunkin Donuts I
love Dunkin Donuts but the fact that you
rest on Duck though it's for your coffee
because it's consistent because I can
get two cream I can I can order two
creams in a medium coffee and it comes
out exactly the way I like it I gotta go
to some
coffee shop named after a Central
American revolutionary and they have one
percent milk I gotta sit there and drink
some weird form of jicama in my problem
with America no I'm not I'm consistency
something America needs to get back to
you're the problem with America dude
I am American Excuse Me Maybe I do order
my lunch meat on Amazon because it comes
the way I like it
consulted it away the way I like it son
of a [ __ ] all right you know when you
go to your friend's house and you're
like yeah I don't really and the mom's
like nah try it you're like I don't like
that I'm just telling you I don't like
it like that and then they're like yeah
I eat it and you're like well now we're
in a situation
I mean you're a man of uh of I don't
mean this insultingly but of simple
taste very simple tastes but you see
it's also you know what a nice way to
put that easy to please
well I don't think you are
I said that out two things I've said out
loud that I've immediately regreted yeah
yeah no no I I yeah I think you're
probably a real pain in the ass at
dinner time I won't eat that I don't
like that no it's just too fancy no no
eating eating I don't have a prop coffee
I just don't like black coffee
that's fine yeah yeah you don't you
don't like to drink the bottom of an
ashtray yeah
cigarette yeah and so when it's like you
know this she's like one percent I mean
yeah dude you're gonna look like you
only drink soda that tastes like celery
why not man I don't care I don't want
grown-up soda it's like soda with a job
I don't want I don't like it yeah so um
but food wise I'm I'm pretty actually
that's the third thing I've said that
immediately I'm like maybe I'm wrong
about that too
wait well I mean so you you'll you'll I
mean I find it fascinating that you're
claiming
that you'll go fancier
because we're not getting to the battle
yet but when I said to you send me a few
Foods you love the first food you wrote
was casseroles I love them which dear
Lord I love them today's battle is
casserole versus salads I am on the team
of salads now we did soup versus salad
on the show before but that was soup
versus salad like like like appetizer
green salad
leafy salad so you're not counting any
leafy salads in this battle uh I do
actually think they could but I also
don't mind regulating it to
salad types
like like like potato macaroni tuna egg
salad you know blah blah blah all still
but basically what we're talking about
is a is a hot mush versus a cold mush
yeah
and we'll get to it later and I mean
there's yeah but the fact that you led
with casseroles which nine times out of
ten come out of a box that has some sort
of character on it you know why because
wild because yeah because I like
animated I like animated representation
of my food yeah I need to know a glove
with eyes made what I'm about to eat
fair enough I need to know a [ __ ] uh
we're on the bonfire we had DJ Lou he
made a casserole and everyone was
disgusted and I realized I remember that
it was the worst I was on that day you
know I was on the day after because you
weren't there and I filled in and it was
can you do you remember what was it was
the most disgusting thing I'd ever heard
it was a tuna casserole with cream of
mushroom uh
what else did it have in it
um did it have oregano that's just a
regular and then it had 15 pieces of
craft singles melted on top
there was something else though too I
don't know delicious there was a did you
like it yeah
I ate it here's the thing
I liked it briefly I turned pretty quick
because after like three bites of not
being hungry you're like I don't like
this that's so disgusting dude
wasn't there a fourth ingredient like
salsa or something like that
there was something else in there it was
cream of mushroom soup that was the that
was the glop
tuna
oregano
oh and then macro it was on shelves and
then crap oh all right yeah you're
leaving out they have shells God damn
dude it was great that is disgusting I
gotta do a shout out real quick simple
man before we press on here I'm gonna
have a sip of this [ __ ] cigar butt uh
all right shout outs to
uh so people at the shows
uh people at my stand-up shows have been
bringing me Happy Meal toys and actual
Happy Meals that's pretty cool
because you're talking about McDonald's
so much on here I love McDonald's did
the fan contact you who actually runs
the Happy Meal toys he was gonna send me
all the toys for you what no yeah what
by the way yeah
he runs the Happy Meal toys he's like in
charge of merchandise for the yeah
please
you want someone happy you really want
Happy Meal toys yes okay your
apartment's pretty filled it doesn't
matter it's it's like this is like a
cool thing that fans are starting to do
where they're showing up bringing me
Happy Meal toys
it's very cool so the other night at the
stand you're gonna get put on a list
dude Asher deverna Aiden deverna James
Anderson and Evan Powers shout out guys
uh thank you they brought me an actual
Happy Meal that had Pokemon cards in it
and
uh two other people whose names I don't
know and I apologize I should have
written them down and I didn't I'm sorry
but shout outs to both of you you know
who you are one woman brought me a Thor
Happy Meal toy in uh San Francisco cool
very cool she was the one that started
she was the Catalyst yeah send pimp your
name if if you could please and also the
this other person she came another woman
came to my show in AC
please send pimp your name she brought
me
one of the Nuggets pimp one of the
Nugget action figures that we looked up
and that's worth funny from the 80s yeah
where they would like transform into
this one was no this no one of the like
McNuggets would think the cowboy hat oh
[ __ ] I remember those yeah and I I said
to her I go don't give this to me it's
worth money and she goes I know I want
you to have it because you'll actually
display it in your house and I did
where is it in the house I have like
trinkets at the center of his front door
yeah some people have you know lines
it's my Marley
Knockerz Chicken McNugget toy from a
Happy Meal
come in
now I have a I have like just action
figures and stuff scattered throughout
my apartment a different place so I just
have it in a place but um
dude it's so cool and then another woman
brought me I can't remember what's
happening military or not but it's a
little red I think it is it's a red
thing that you squeeze and the eyes pop
out so anyway any of you watching send
your names to pimp please I want to give
you proper shout outs but this cool
trend is happening where people are
again we didn't request this or anything
people have their own fruition fans are
showing up at shows with Happy Meal
items and that's always that is really
awesome very very cool my fans do this
thing where they hand me pieces of paper
and it's their social security number
and I just go steal their identity yeah
yeah no my other fans are doing
something cool where they just give me
cash
they get they bring a nod of cash they
give it to me we they kiss me on both I
like to do a little Mafia greeting they
give me a kiss on both cheeks they hand
me money
dude if you start just getting manila
envelopes yeah the uh also shout out to
the baloney boys
uh who are a punk band out of they're
off the West Coast I think I think out
of San Fran I remember anyway they sent
me their AP uh it's awesome check it out
it's on um you know iTunes and all that
I mean Apple music and all that stuff
now and satify is an alliteration yeah
that is but bologna boys very fun Punk
if you like the Black Flag stuff in the
vein of TV party you'll really like
these guys they're great and they
suggested you should do a baloney battle
at some point which we're gonna do just
not today we talked about maybe doing
but we both love baloney love baloney
um one one I thought of doing with you
was bologna versus hot dogs
but both I do too uh it's tough but I
used to take baloney slices and put a
little rain like a line of ranch and
then roll it up that's disgusting Cowboy
Taco damn that's disgusting
wow that's disgusting
that's disgusting Dan disgustingly
delicious folks what are your favorite
holiday meals what are your favorite
holiday activities what are your
favorite holiday traditions I'll tell
you some of mine
cooking the food
eating food thinking about the food
what food
meat based food butcher box you know
where this is going butcher box is
taking all the guesswork out of finding
high quality Meat and seafood you can
trust especially great and handy during
this holiday season you want to prep
those meals you want to prep those meals
for the people that you love uh or maybe
you want to prep some meals for some
strangers maybe you want to do a little
Charity maybe you just want to cook for
yourself I don't know the point is is if
you're gonna cook and if you're gonna
cook meat you want quality involved in
that process and you want that quality
to not cost you an arm and a leg you
want it to not be inconvenient and you
want it to basically come to your
doorstep and that's why butcher Box is
doing all the right stuff in a great way
you're going to enjoy a high high range
of high quality cuts that are just hard
to come by at the grocery store at an
amazing value like this uh exclusive
member deals are there so you can save
big on your favorite Cuts uh there's
recipe inspiration guides tips hacks
some are even personalized uh so you can
cook up all the the fun meals that you
want to cook up
um I love steak personally and I
actually think red meat gets sidelined a
lot at how during the holidays and I
think butcher box helps you bring high
quality steak into the mix and allows
you to cook and add some red meat to the
holiday spread and and trust me people
love it people love it if you if you
suggest it beforehand people are
hesitant you set it on that table it
goes baby it goes I'm telling you anyway
uh Awesome by the way gift butcher box
to somebody it's a great gift at
Christmas time for for the person who
has everything uh as they say anyway the
holiday season is made better it's made
tastier with butcher box for a limited
time they're offering our listeners
ground beef for life
and 10 off your first order
that's ground beef for Life plus 10 off
your first order you sign up today at
butcherbox.com taste buds use that promo
code taste buds get 10 off your first
box and ground beef for life during your
membership that's butcher box that's
butcherbox.com taste buds and use that
promo code taste buds to claim this deal
folks this episode of taste buds is
sponsored by betterhelp that's better
help
help h-e-l-p you heard me
you need it we all need it it's hard to
find sometimes it's hard to find the
motivation to get the help you need I
love better help I use better help uh
life does not come with a user manual
people
so when it's not working for you it's
very easy to feel stuck think about how
stuck you feel when you do have a user
manual for something and that thing is
not working life doesn't have that so
the the feeling of stuckness if you will
can be quite overwhelming better help is
offering you the help you need
therapists that are trained to help you
figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and learning helping you learn
to to get those productive coping skills
and that makes therapy the closest thing
to a guided tour
of the complex engine that you call you
that's as close as you're going to get
better help is offering you the closest
thing to the user manual betterhelp has
connected over three million people with
licensed therapists it's convenient it's
accessible anywhere a hundred percent
online I'm telling you I use it
uh my therapist we we do as of now we do
the video meets but we have the option
of always switching to phone if we want
you can you can you can check in through
text and things like that uh it's very
accommodating and by it's affordable the
price of it is it is priced as
the more affordable therapy sessions are
priced even through Insurance a lot of
the time now it is true that sometimes
your insurance could cover all costs I
will tell you people have a lot of
problems with that unfortunately it's
the way the system works unfortunately I
have had many problems with that
unfortunately and by problems I mean
calling uh um uh facilities and not
getting calls back calling people and
they they don't have room for new
clients whatever you're offered a very
limited selection you're offered a very
limited amount of resources for for what
you need and and something you need in a
time-sensitive manner better help is
here to help you get around all of that
to make it an affordable thing when you
step outside of the system you step
outside of the system usually you're
finding people charging you hundreds of
dollars an hour it's it's
it's a lot it's a lot and so is life and
that's why better help is amazing
the the the here's the thing as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched three million people
with professionally licensed therapists
as I said these people are vetted
and available 100 online okay and here's
all you got to do you fill out a brief
questionnaire and then you get matched
with a therapist that's it if things
aren't clicking you can easily switch to
a new therapist anytime that's also
tough sometimes when you're you know
they make it easy to do that this
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic nothing this is it learn more
and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com tastebuds that's better
help
help.com tastebuds get 10 off your first
month
sorry business
so you rolling bologna with ranch
dressing in the middle I mean my God oh
my talk about a Russian doll of garbage
[Laughter]
do you ever see that do you ever see
that movie the the watch with Vince
Vaughn no that was right after George
Floyd remember not George Floyd uh Tavon
uh yeah with uh Trayvon Martin yeah and
George Zimmer George Zimmerman and they
I mean that happened like the week they
had to change the name from neighborhood
watch to the watch yeah I believe I
think that's movies is that crazy that
movies happen like that where they're
like we got this crazy high school story
of these two out outside boys who want
to change the way the high school was
Columbine we can't release it yeah yeah
no when they were to watch their
fighting aliens so it's like
Ghostbusters but otherwise aliens
are they legal what does that represent
Joseph but there's a scene in Ben
Stiller's house where Vince Vaughn finds
Russian dolls it's like opening up and
he goes he goes oh my God look at that
look at that there's another one inside
hold on hold on wait a minute
there's another one he literally doesn't
understand he's never seen one yeah he
just keeps doing it and he and benzo is
like okay please just put that down and
he's like he's like
I'm halfway in buddy I gotta see how far
it goes
oh oh my God he's so blown away by it
it's a it's really funny crazy thing
about Vince Vaughn is he can get to that
point where he still has his fastball
when he just reacts to stuff he's so
funny still yeah did you see um
watch that movie
um creepy oh okay I think creepy 99
rounds or what's it called I just looked
up films that were impacted by 911
happening
uh Tom Hanks on the week of 9 11 decided
to officially end the sequel to Forrest
Gump because I felt meaningless no but
did you know in the sequel to Forrest
Gump there was a scene where you saw the
towers go down no shut the [ __ ] up yeah
yeah how do you know that you can read
the synopsis of Forrest Gump part 2 on
the internet I was friends with a couple
hijackers and they didn't tell me what
they was gonna do yeah there's like it's
like when you read it it's [ __ ]
Forrest Gump is a dog [ __ ] movie oh we
all got swept away in the moment let's
get in except for one man one man was
not swept away you're you're it's simple
your simple brain magic won't work on
Joe deroza I saw through it can't
hypnotize me yeah your mom gets you into
school it's gross
that would be stinks ass and the
technology didn't hold up well yeah it
now looks like uh who's the guy do you
think you think the guy wait wait wait
it was the guy Steve owner Kirk the guy
did the thumbs that Talked oh yeah
that's what that that's what those seeds
look like I haven't watched it looks
like upside down mouth on John F
Kennedy's like high Firefox
that's Steve odakirk yeah that's that's
yeah we're like I don't know yeah yeah
yeah do you think in the sequel it was
Forest that gave you know how like when
Force gives all the ideas to like [ __ ]
happens or whatever
do you think there was a part where he
was there was just like an Al Qaeda
member and he's like but the United
States is so strong he's like I would
just take out a couple of their
buildings
dude you know the world World Trade
Center was also a financial Capital dude
did when you read the synopsis
it's not that far off from that really
like when you like there are there are
full articles online about like so the
forest comes to synopsis has leaked and
it is insane like because like they it's
crazy like one of the things literally
was like he's on the bench and that you
see the towers like Drop behind him or
something it was something crazy like
that it was crew it was crazy like but
that movie when you go back and watch it
is batshit yeah
it's bad [ __ ] you got [ __ ] Chinese
crawling around on the ground with no
legs also talking about shrimp it's wild
Forrest Gump really does treat
Lieutenant Dan just comes in and wrecks
this guy's life this guy's a military
man through and through yeah
generationally and son of a [ __ ] dude I
love the actor that plays Bubba I love
that actor you can't unsee Bubba once
you see Forrest Gump yeah like once you
see that movie like he's in heat and
he's awesome he's the guy that yeah the
one last he's the guy in the that works
in the oh no he's a cop he's a cop he's
a Pacino's partner he's the one that
doesn't get killed and he's like a
badass but like half halfway through it
yeah you see him making that face I
gotta talk about shrimp instead of
finding out where the hell this Heist is
going I'm reading heat too right now
Michael Mann and and another author
wrote a sequel to heat it's called
wango's Revenge it just came out it's
about all it's about Vince and Hannah
who's Pacino's character hunting down
Val Kilmer's character after he drives
away at the end
and then there's a prequel heist with De
Niro and his crew and it jumps back and
forth and it is awesome Okay and like
dude like you're reading it like you're
reading it reading it and like
it finally gets to the part where like
Pacino likes like Springs into action is
like on the scene and it's written ex
it's it's exactly what you want like
he's interrogating
um Jon Voight's character at one point
and he's like he's like you know and
he's like so and so does that ring a
bell and uh John voice like ring a bell
and he's like Bill Bill ding ding
[ __ ] like and he's doing he's
doing all the Pacino talk from the movie
and you're like it's so fun to read in
the voices because that was Pacino right
before he completely left completely
loose oh it's wow he was still a little
of you know like popping he's popping
speed in the book too which which
explains why he acts the way he does in
the movie which they had to write
afterwards because we got to make an
excuse for this this is [ __ ] ball but
like good there was one other movie
impacted by oh sorry oh sorry uh Jackie
Chan was supposed to start filming a
movie called nosebleed which was about a
window washer on the World Trade Center
who foils a terrorist clock
Jesus was it a kung fu movie or is it
like one of those comedies no it was a
debate movie
it's comedies like little kids and [ __ ]
yeah but he does Kung Fu in all of them
well yeah but you know what I mean
you're not getting a movie with Jackie
Chan or he's not kicking something was
this a Frankie Muniz type vehicle or was
this more of a bronx Rumble in the Bronx
isn't what I'm asking it feels like a
die hard from yeah okay it's absolutely
a die-hard thing which really bugged me
because the anniversary of Die Hard like
the 30th Anniversary or whatever came
out uh-huh maybe even the 35th and Bruce
Willis posted a picture on Instagram
on top of the tower and he was like
can't believe I'm back here I was like
yeah you're not John McLean
you didn't have to jump off of that
Tower you were on a movie set and it was
all taken care of everything was okay
it's weird to be like here I am again
where it all went down you didn't go
through that you acted like that how
dare you
he went through it he said come to said
I have a cup of coffee
you don't play a role like that unless
you're yeah yeah well can you not go to
the airport in Detroit or whatever the
[ __ ] it went down and second one I
remember I remember we saw Die Hard 2 we
were about 11. when Die Hard 2 came out
maybe 12. and we went to see it and my
friend Scott who to this day is one of
my closest you've met Scott we went to
his house
it's got rules one of my oldest in my
best oldest best friend anyway and he
goes
come on dude two Christmases in a row
and it was like such a weird thing for a
12 year old to understand and I was like
we're the cynical talk and I was like
what are you talking about dude shut up
what are you talking about like I
couldn't handle it look at that you
could tell it's not even raining in the
background look
you see where the rain ends right there
you're like 12.
seven years old he's going he was and
I'm not seven years old ago Scott you
excited for Christmas and he goes
Santa's going to every house
every house by the way I'm not joking he
was managing our local Radio Shack at
17. yeah don't be surprised grown men
working under him I was like what is
wrong with you dude
when you're 12 and you're popping holes
and [ __ ] theories and [ __ ] through
the plots
goodbye anyway two Christmases
all right folks let's get to the battle
pimp we got to be right we're good here
all right let's go that's when I told
those two kids if you don't like the
people in your high school you should
just do something about it
guns are very easy to get yeah trench
coats are nice I like a trench color it
makes you look like an angel of death
he's just behind all the terrible [ __ ]
that's so funny
yeah dark Forrest Gump yo so if you
don't lock your little beautiful
daughter you should do something about
it Mr Ramsay
get that
yeah yeah yeah that's funny dude that's
so [ __ ] funny I don't know it might
be going to Iraq and take down a
dictator
[Laughter]
ah [ __ ] oh my God all right why are you
sorry what are you sorry for having fun
I'm sorry sorry I'm having such a good
time bringing Joy to the [ __ ] world I
need it in my life dude
I'm sitting here walking a tightrope
between a podcast and running a bar I
know dude I don't know if I'm coming or
going right now I don't know which Joe I
get I don't know if I get [ __ ]
businessman Joe or my pal Joe DeRosa who
knows all right delicious and can you
call the end of your podcast defrag
that's where you just let it all out I
wish I knew what Joe I got every morning
yeah don't we all bad don't we all there
we go no one told me when you get to
your late 30s you just wake up scared oh
welcome to the [ __ ] dude welcome to the
show baby lady hit 45 [ __ ] you don't
even know what downhill is dude dude I
love going downhill I've been doing a
joke about that recently on stage where
people are like oh it's all downhill
from here and I'm like good I love going
downhill
foreign
dude you have no idea dude you're right
you're gonna start picking up speed soon
dude
[Laughter]
yeah getting older is like it's like
when you have that panic attack on weed
yeah and you go I can handle it I can
handle it you go oh my God it's getting
worse yeah and then you're like you
can't get worse than this you're like
yes it can it's a perfect description
and it just keeps going you're like I'll
tell you right now the same panic I used
to get at like 17 when I was smoking too
much weed is every morning for me now
you just wake up in that state well and
that's that's this and we'll get to the
battle relax
we're getting to it I swear fans uh the
that's the saddest part about getting
older is you start to realize you're as
Bert Kreischer calls it treat whatever
your treat is yeah Vines whiskey yours
is weed yeah is
not only soothing that panic but
creating it yeah it's crazy so you're
like you're you're in a cycle I mean I
eat because I'm unhappy and I had about
a happy because
it's you're in it dude oh you're you're
you're on the you're you're you're
you're Griswold right now in London dude
I can't get left it's incredible
I feel it I feel like the wheels are
moving now another sip of black coffee
I'm a different person now
that stuff's gonna taste like candy to
you in two months I go I'm solving all
the cases yeah dude give it some time
dude drink a pot of that every morning I
just wake up and I go you know what I
don't like
unions that are too nosy
the Stefano called me once on a 98
degree day and he goes what are you
doing today I go nothing it's too hot
and he goes what do you do on a day like
today you just sit inside drink coffee
and think
I go that's exactly what I'm doing and
it's not good dude sips of hot coffee a
whole pot every morning baby that's
crazy huh that's crazy it's a small pot
okay it's a mini pot but it's still a
pot it's still three solid cups dude in
your Journal when they find it among
your collections when you get when you
get wrongfully accused of being a serial
killer when you dive and they come and
take your body out they go oh that's my
trinkets yeah we gotta dig through this
dude that's what they're gonna call the
documentary trinkets
but it's it's also it's or uh yeah it's
also got to be the girl that disappeared
that you got blamed for it's like the
Allison daily uh dude
um and here's the craziest part about my
three to four cups of black coffee every
morning
I'm drinking coffee like a foreman
out of a mug of a four-year-old yeah so
it's a [ __ ] Yoda head yeah so I got
the Smurfs on it yeah I'm pounding it
yeah you do it through a [ __ ] curly
straw yeah
this plate display new sponsor display
new sponsor alert it's displayed One of
a Kind metal posters designed to capture
your unique passions and interest this
plate created a 21st century canvas
that's sturdy magnet mounted and durable
enough to withstand a lifetime of
intense staring uh but look staring is
only half the fun you can customize
collect and rearrange them at will it's
very cool they're metal posters they're
they have magnetic mounts so you can set
the mounts and you can take the poster
down and put up a different poster easy
peasy I'm a person that rearranges his
uh living space frequently
uh I'll decide one day that I hate
everything and you move it all around
and I do have a lot of stuff on my walls
uh uh some of it is mounted with just
you know sticky tape stuff and then
other things are nailed and hung and
whatever uh and I can tell you anytime
you move any of that it sucks because
now there's holes or there's residue or
whatever
and you know all because what because
you want to have a different thing
hanging in that place than what you had
hang in there and that's what this plate
is allowing you to do you go all right
I'm moving everything around I want a
different piece of art there pop that
off pop something new on boom you're out
the door uh they have branded and
artistic artwork they have over a
million designs available to everyone uh
stuff from Marvel DC Star Wars uh
Netflix NASA South Park plenty of games
plenty of movies everybody can find
something for yourself uh I I you know I
like they have a they have a vintage and
a retro section which I like a lot like
old movie posters and things that are
inspired by old movie posters and stuff
like that and I thought that that was
really really cool this plate they
deliver the products worldwide worldwide
worldwide and only four to five business
days it's a perfect alternative for
standard paper posters that often get
damaged I didn't mention that sometimes
when you move something it gets damaged
this won't happen happen
and again no marks on the wall
eco-friendly every design sold uh uh oh
how about this every design that is sold
they are going to plant one tree that's
nice
right now this place is having the big
dis oh God I can't talk right now this
plate is having the biggest discount
ever for buying one to two designs you
get 35 percent off for buying three to
four designs you get 39 off if you buy
five or more you're gonna get 44 off
Jesus that's almost half off use the
link in the description the discount is
applied automatically a checkout go to
displate.com tastebuds that's
d-i-s-p-l-a-t-e.com slash taste buds and
use code tastebuds at checkout display
collect your passions
folks
let's talk daily fantasy let's talk make
an entries
let's talk player projections
what am I talking we're talking about
prize picks that's what we're talking
about you know what I'm talking about
all right how do you do it it's easy you
go to the prize picks app
you you want to do some of your daily
fantasy sports thing on there you you
make your entries as simply as possible
they're helping you out with player
projections uh and you win you win if
you win you win and it's and it's easy
to to capitalize on if you win uh
hopefully you win
um
they give me an example to read to you
because they know how inept I am with
sports information
um
and I am but I always say this this
aspect of sports I enjoy very much I
just wish I knew more so I was better at
it and prize picks actually helps me a
guy like me with that so you say tonight
a picture I'm taking Patrick Mahomes to
throw for more than 320 passing yards
Derek Henry to rush for less than 85
yards Cooper cup
which is my favorite name ever for an
athlete to score more than half 0.5
touchdowns and Tyree killed a catch less
than 3.5 passes you you get how this
works
you pick two to six players if they will
uh if they're gonna go score more or
less
then the prize picks projection which
prize picks is supplying you and you can
win up to 25 times your money or or
entry on an entry excuse me up to 25
times your money on an entry I mean I
think that's great you're not competing
against other people which I like just
you versus projections I like this it's
fun prize picks offers projections on
any sport you want to watch that's the
other thing I like there yeah we're
talking NFL NBA NLB uh NHL PGA college
football men's college basketball
women's college basketball uh soccer
WNBA Esports NASCAR Cricket for God's
sakes it goes on and on so even a guy
like me can find something that he sort
of understands entries can be made in 60
seconds or less it's that easy I also
like that because I'm impatient
and and you got safe and fast
withdrawals how awesome is that
operational right now in 30 States and
over 30 States actually and in Canada
you're going to download the prize picks
app or go to prize picks.com
you can sign up today and play daily
fantasy sports first time users can
receive 100 instant deposit to match up
to a hundred dollars when you use the
promo code taste buds so that means if
you deposit a hundred dollars
uh or less price picks will give you a
hundred dollars or less it will match
whatever you put in up to a cap of a
hundred dollars if you deposit 50 prize
picks will give you you get it anyway
don't forget you enter the promo code
taste buds at sign up for an instant
deposit match of up to a hundred dollars
prize picks
and I have a little balcony I have a
little Terrace on my apartment so I can
walk out onto it like like Pacino and
heat like taking it looking over the
city
dude I love it I'm sorry that I was out
making sandwich
I'm sorry that the Happy Meal toys got
dried out it's heavy dude you got no
idea I love it I got a baby in a
microwave
dude I um
what are your shits like
a potato gun usually pretty good if I'm
eating if I eat right good no because
because the caffeine helps it like yeah
and it's look it's all what your body
can handle like caffeine I don't process
caffeine in a bad way
it doesn't get me jittery it doesn't
keep me away I could literally drink
coffee before I went to bed and I could
still go to bed I've had a coffee and
took a nap yeah so it doesn't like rock
my system it's more ritualistic in the
morning it gets me like starting a
routine of fluids for the day and and
it's it wakes me up it's warm and I love
it it's my it's as a pothead I I find it
necessary yeah it's a balancing act oh
when I was smoking Stooges
oh dude forget it I used to go I had for
five years when I was still drinking and
smoking I had the same morning routine
every I would wake up
I would go down the street to Dunkin
Donuts I'd get a medium coffee and then
I would smoke a cigarette on the way
home by the time I got home and put that
cigarette out I was ready to poop go
poop come back out have another
cigarette with the coffee I'm getting
shaky just thinking about it because I
remember doing that and like you would
get that empty stomach feeling
and you you'd get like a little like
whoo all right let me sit down for a
second
that's one of the reasons I stopped
smoking but um
but anyway our battle today
was not coffee it's not cigarettes it's
not any of those things it's casseroles
versus salads
and I will open this argument up by
saying Dan I don't know who you think
you are to come on this show the first
time ever and try to step in the ring
with me against potato salad tuna salad
egg salad macaroni salad pasta salad
coleslaw dog what are you even thinking
and we're not even getting into the
variations of each we're just talking
straight across the board all I hear is
germs
sickness all those things you're dealing
with expound
let them let them stay out too long and
what happens well what kind of animals
leave an amount everyone
everyone no one properly takes care of a
salad a potato salad a macaroni salad
you go to a barbecue that thing's been
outside for three hours right so you're
getting it's got a spoiled mayonnaise
it's got a shelf life it does it's got a
quick shelf life that's got a very quick
show those good things do no it's not
it's a hot strip most Pleasures are
Fleet stripper it's heading right to
disaster and you know that sure things
are beautiful now in the black light
while she's got those fake eyelashes on
but in the morning where are you going
to be yeah you know who's going to be
there in the morning a casserole
casserole in the fridge ready for a
reason yeah casserole something that
looks like [ __ ] from the second it comes
out of the oven to the second this is
what I hate about a casserole no matter
how many people stick their foods and
sporks in it and no matter how eaten it
is it looks the same that is disgusting
dude [ __ ] that is disgusting it's got
several life forms dude
how older gentlemen when we get gray in
our hair we start looking a little
better that's casserole today that's the
other reason I don't like a casserole a
person could eat directly out of the
dish with their fork and you wouldn't be
able to tell you can cover it up
disgusting I love it no dude I love a
history you can mend like a fat man
shoving uh paper towel into the hole of
a cake to cover where he ate away well
that's better you could do it with a
casserole it's better than the cold
chaos you're putting in front of me
where I'm going through a potato salad
the raisin comes out of nowhere that's
all this life is just called chaos I got
news for you buddy Welcome to the real
world pal I think you if you think it's
all tucked into a nice clear dish and
your mom pulls out of the oven it ain't
oh this macaroni salad is so delicious
and zesty why are there peas in it why
is just a random Peach I won't argue I
won't argue that I I'm not a big
macaroni salad guy and when it's got P I
like pasta salad I don't like macaroni
salad because macaroni salad is
mayonnaise and especially if you're
throwing peas in the carrot the cubes
into it nothing's worse than a carrot
Cube yeah I was just gonna say carrot
Cuban peas showing up you think you
don't got peas running through yeah you
think you don't got peas running through
your goddamn uh casseroles all peas and
carrots are welcome in a casserole
[ __ ] guess what dude I'm sorry that
I'm sorry that we have an open lifestyle
oh you want to bring your friend in
bring your friend into your casserole
that's beef dude that's beef let's put
beef in a casserole yeah and it'll be
delicious yeah and here's why Dan here's
why and it won't always be delicious and
you goddamn know it won't always be if
it's warm but here's why we can put beef
in a casserole here's why we could put
beef in anything or I'm sorry here's why
we put anything in a casserole because
there's no Nuance there's no
craftsmanship there's no skill it's put
whatever [ __ ] you pulled out of the
fridge into a bowl and as long as you
dump salt by the way the dish is called
cat a casserole that's how low rent this
platter is they named it after the dish
imagine if somebody gave you a bowl of
soup and they go here this is called
bowl of soup it's in the name too no
they say here's some soup they don't go
here's Bowl oh you don't go what is this
they go it's Bowl I go all right here
you go what's bowl and they go anything
you put inside this because it's garbage
casseroles everyone leads with the name
of the casserole here is a tuna
casserole nobody this is what my mom
said frequently growing up frequently
growing up I'm gonna make a casserole
for dinner and then you go what what in
it yeah you gotta ask specifics nobody
ever said I'm gonna make a pot nobody
ever said I'm gonna make a pan I'm gonna
say one word that isn't casserole that
is a casserole that's you're immediately
gonna go with right lasagna lasagna is
the only good one you got what lasagna
and seven layer pizza dip those are the
only two ones you got that's it I'll
give you a taco dip occasionally people
usually [ __ ] those up seven layers
people usually [ __ ] up the cheese here's
the thing about casserole people usually
[ __ ] up the taco dip in casseroles you
got you got meat and melted cheese all
the time those are the two hits yeah I
mean that's the Keith and Mick what of
every castron can't put this together
exactly
exactly I can't believe you think that's
a plus I love it I love you know what if
I'm gonna pull a bat a hit consistency
you got a half bag of shredded cheese
yes all right you you show me a half bag
of shredded cheese half a pound of
bologna and a box of noodles and I'll
show you a casserole great that's
something to be proud about and let's
dance then you know what because then
you can eat and you can work on the
bigger problems
all right listen if you want to not
think sure okay but also putting a
potato salad together is not rocket
science but it takes enough care that
it's worth dude you show up let me tell
you something and this is an argument we
go to a lot on the show
you show up to a party yeah with a bowl
and they go once then you go I made
potato salad people go holy [ __ ] no they
go oh you're in a rush no they don't
casserole they go they go you took time
to bake it
again no no they don't say that because
I'll tell you what you said thank you
for bringing it on I know I know it no I
know it they don't say that I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why I'll tell you
why because you show them the guest show
the first thing you say is I need to use
your oven and you go you [ __ ] rag
I got three ovens going full of [ __ ] I
don't have time for this right now
listen and you and yours you and your
side dish life I'm over here living an
entree existence I'm bringing an entree
dude if you're eating a casserole as an
entree and it's nice then thank you for
working so hard to make America great if
you if when you if you want to be old
[ __ ] Barbecue on a Tuesday Joe just
got money to throw around on it now
McDonald's toys
when you show up a potato salad then
they go oh my God would you put in it
and then you start to share your recipe
you go well I might do it my mom had a
we use a little sour cream and scallions
whatever it is it's so exciting it's a
Dave our head chef guy here he he one
day comes in he goes he goes I want to
show you something this is a pasta salad
I made he gave me a bite of this [ __ ] I
wanted to kiss him it was so good and
the craftsmanship that and as I'm eating
and he's going he's going so this is
what I did I chopped up this I put this
I put that that thing you're tasting me
you can't quite put your finger on
that's another thing you could always
say with a salad
you know that you know it the thing you
can't quite put your finger on that's
Ginger or whatever that's funny because
the the way you did that with a
casserole it sounds like you're
explaining a casserole no no because I
put this in and then I put this little
ingredient you might not get it here's
what a casserole is another thing you
can't put your finger on and I go
is it fingers because this looks like it
has fingers in it this looks like you
put fingers into a dish and cooked it
when you get a salad when you get a cold
salad you got limited time
from the second that [ __ ] plastic
comes off it and you put it outside you
got limited time before you got to put
it back in the refrigerator buddy you
got limited time on the casserole too I
got hit I got news for you casserole you
can eat room temperature
and it sucks nah it's still it's still
pretty good it sucks and I'll tell you
this too aside from lasagna the only
main course casserole that exists that's
[ __ ] okay all of them are made no
they're not they're all side dishes and
dips and you know it
side dishes are good they're good dips
but they're not good sizes that's it
they're side dishes dude and a dip is
just an all day long if you if you put
something if you dare put something
where the base ingredient is elbow
macaroni in front of me it is not a side
dish I'll flip the table over if it's
elbow macaroni or tiny shells already oh
my stomach's about to be a beach covered
in shells God the just picture picture
the pasta picnic picture the family
get-together of the pastas and then
elbow macaroni shows up and you go why
do we have to have this trash in our
family I love it lasagna is there it's
like Saint germain's joke about Evan
Williams
with all the with all like Jack Jim not
Jim um Johnny Walker and everybody
that's what elbow macaroni is that's
what every macaroni
casseroles are the only thing where you
can go don't you dare put that dollar 79
box of Barilla spaghetti into that
casserole you use the cheap [ __ ] this is
the elbow macaroni by the way dude
casseroles can be as elegant as you want
them to be
I'll give you one a great lasagna you
got nothing after lasagna you know it is
my one
figure I was like got him and then I
didn't think of any backups what's your
favorite don't say lasagna what's your
favorite cat like what's a
what's a
give me a turkey tetrazzini oh my God oh
my God let me tell you how disgusting
that is it's delicious every
Thanksgiving
me and Keith Robinson used to call Mike
vecchione and trash him and say that
you're not allowed to celebrate this day
because you're Italian and we would then
begin to make up
Italian Thanksgiving dishes to mock him
in his Heritage and in my bed on my best
day in all the years we did it yeah I
couldn't have come up with turkey Tetris
I mean that sounds like a My Blue Heaven
joke what the [ __ ] Soder I love it
turkey what is in that mushrooms turkey
bread crumbs
cream of mushroom soup oh my god dude
welcome hey what kind of noodles Tetris
is Tetris you can do not you can do
spaghetti
[Laughter]
casseroles the cellular casserole should
be it looks the same coming up as it did
going in and I nothing changes you know
what I read from that consistency and I
think consistency is pretty cool also
it's the best winter food cold food a
casserole is a great cold weather you're
you're out of your your you're out of
your mind I'm sorry you're over here
summering in the Hamptons with all your
expensive potato salad ah dude I'm over
here I'm over here in a three-story
walk-up with real working people having
a corner slice of a casserole you go you
go into Annie Deli you go into any
Burger Shop you go into any hot dog
joint whatever like any basically like
lunch variations of lunch foods
and you get yourself a hoagie a club
sandwich a burger a dog whatever it is
and then you go what are your and then
the waitress goes what do you want for
your side and you go what are my options
she goes fried she go that's a given
yeah chips that's a given then she goes
we also have potato or macaroni salad
you're like baby marry me
here we go if she said turkey Tetris
I already ordered my entree I go thank
you next time I'll have that as my own
okay then I'll then I'll replace it then
I'll replace it you know it how I just
saw it on your face you know how excited
you get when they go we got potatoes I
love it there you go and you go what
kind
and if she says vinegar base you go God
damn it if she goes Mayo based she goes
tradition come on what are we animals
hang out oh my god let's get it going
I have never once ever in in as a main
course option in a restaurant gotten
excited about a casserole I've never
even seen a casserole on a menu except
lasagna
baby it's coming
that is it's dark stuff maybe maybe uh
we're gonna maybe there's a new
restaurant coming that's specifically
just casseroles look you might have
something there honestly you might
honestly I don't think that's a bad idea
if you had a really good chance it's
catchy enough that's a pet rock idea
like get in get your million get out to
reference heat once again take the money
okay when you feel that score again
leave town that's great please open up
next door yeah dude I'm gonna do dude oh
that I'd collab with you the uh we're
gonna do that how's that not the battle
winner when Joe goes oh that's a good
idea I'll collab with you we're gonna go
to the phones so we so we go we go to
hear what people are saying and then
we'll do closing arguments
uh it's hard to go wrong with salad babe
if it was called Joe lid it might be a
different story all right I get it very
funny PS Joe I love you thank you sir uh
salads I didn't even get this people are
gonna put salad to salads oh yeah
somebody just wrote casseroles and they
capitalized ass
be the winner I think that might be the
restaurant name just have chicks with
fat dunkers guys give me one second okay
ready
salad makes you feel better about the
other food you're about to consume wow
these guys are talking about green salad
and which was on the table we didn't
even get into it casserole babes that's
a meal salads are great as an app though
yeah I listen I don't want to act like
I'm besmirching salads love a macaroni
salad love a potato salad love a Caesar
salad but I'm talking about an entree no
one brings salad when your uncle dies
yep it's true exactly casseroles equal
death team salad oh that's a one two
damn dude
yeah that was I was all right no the
first guy was being pro casserole it's a
comfort food casserole are worse than
the name casserole uh I don't get that
this is a hard one because there are
gross salads and gross casseroles
casseroles are made by people who have
given them given up on themselves and on
life I wouldn't disagree with that
broccoli casserole sweet potato
casserole salads are the food my food
eats
we've heard that argument before but
it's not a bad argument Castro's can
take a walk if I wanted a bunch of
mushed up trash in a pan I'd go get
Skillet queso at Chili's uh by the way I
think you could consider Skillet queso a
casserole
that's what she I think that's what
they're saying well then thank you thank
you for adding to my point this is a
great point from from coet I can pick
out the stuff I don't like from a salad
that's a great Point yeah
that is you can't do that heat analogy a
casserole is the heist you either enter
your ass you get a slice of that
casserole you got to go through that
whole casserole yeah that is a good
point yeah this is it right now I need a
decision right now in or out do you want
to slice a casserole
[Laughter]
all right uh let's see here that's a
good point uh this is oh wait that's
aside from the green bean casseroles can
take a walk oh gravy casserole it's
phenomenal and what a great side that's
my favorite side dish of all time and I
forgot I completely forgot
at 95 years old that's the only thing my
grandma can still throw yeah at
Thanksgiving that's my favorite it's
great I'm like somebody better have made
it turkey with oh and a slice of
cranberry casseroles are made up of
everything that no one wanted to eat in
the first place so you throw it into a
pan and cook it hoping it's eatable they
keep saying pan it's not a pan it's a
dish yeah casseroles are the cake of
non-dessert food most salads are just
sad excuses that's interesting it is
interesting and I never thought of a
casserole as a cake wow baked here's a
good one for you is shepherd's pie a
casserole if so that's it right there
for the win Shepherd and meat shepherd's
pie meat pies those are casseroles I
would go as far as I say a chicken pot
pie is a casserole you got carrots peas
thank you sir whoever that brave Angel
was Chloe says imagine if you turned up
at Thanksgiving with a salad yeah
imagine if Chloe it'd actually be nice
that's something healthy on the table no
they're like why are you bringing Labor
Day [ __ ] when we're when we're
celebrating Thanksgiving no one has ever
gotten excited about any kind of salad
unless one is getting tossed casseroles
all day my casserole family's strong
we're baked together the crunchy part of
every top the top of every casserole
gives me life God I love good bread
crumbs on the top or something crunchy
no one is satisfied eating a salad ever
yep that's not true
it just takes more salad to satisfy you
well this kid's bringing up tater tot
casserole yeah why not never had it but
I want it yeah welcome to the party dude
yeah uh here's the thing about a
casserole lifestyle
as everyone knows this casserole
lifestyle you welcome all things
we're ready we're ready for anything
salad's damn you might have won this
they have some yeah I'm just reading the
responses here let's give our win to at
the Wellington for cash with Ash or
rolls which by the way I want to talk to
you I want to I want to talk to
Wellington hold on a second follow Jake
at the Wellington 9 at the Wellington
nine he's our winner today Jake you and
I have to have a conversation going
forward about the business idea of
making the restaurant casseroles where
girls it's like it's like Hooters just
girls with big dumpers bring you very
very clever I love it I love it all
right closing arguments
I like a food that brings
people together that comforts
that fulfills
and that
doesn't take a lot
pull off yeah so you want to bring
together people with the least amount of
Love possible no that's what that's what
it says no I don't want them to work
hard I want them to hey give me your
tired you're poor
have I heard that before this great
nation and this great nation is a
casserole and we gotta get back to being
a great Castle well Dan this great
nation is a casserole and it's a [ __ ]
show and it's a [ __ ] show for a reason
start telling everybody that they're all
chefs you get casserole and guess you
start letting anybody think they know
how to cook you're getting a little bit
casseroles some guy saying I threw peas
and gummy bears into a dish and baked it
at 350. that's a dish no it's not it's a
casserole all right well salads well
take my soul and throw me in a white
glove with a red nose and eyes on it
salads are harder to make no salads are
healthier for you that's true and salads
aren't often aren't always as delicious
as casseroles but that's why this
country is on its knees right now
because people only want the easy way
out the easy thing to swallow well if
you want to make this place great folks
you're gonna have to work for it and
salads are the work Joe the rent is just
too damn High
food is expensive gas is astronomical
and maybe a nice Corner slice of a warm
casserole with some bread crumbs on top
something crunchy then warm and hot
you're into breadcrumbs you're into
expensive ingredients I I want to make a
potato salad I need three things
salt mayo and potatoes and I got it
honestly from where I'm saying that
sounds like a cold casserole
all right Dan plug whatever you want to
plug and then we and then we just do the
Humble Pie segment uh danceoder.com for
all live tour dates at Dan Soder on
Instagram and Twitter I'm on the road
I'll be going to DC Dallas Houston a
bunch of places Cleveland so
danceoder.com for tickets
Joe to Rosa comedy on Instagram and
Twitter
uh I was am I doing the math right pimp
this is the week of September 5th now
this comes out Memorial Day right yep or
Labor Day I mean uh I believe folk uh
and after that I'm all over the place in
the fall I'm back on the road folks I'm
by the way touring with the show I'm not
just coming at you throwing new stuff at
you I never I Never Promised You a Rose
Garden is the name of the show it's a
full hour it's got a theme it's I'm very
proud of it it might be the best thing
I've ever done Anyway come see me
jodarosa info for all tickets and show
information Joey
rosesnyc.com where we are right now come
see us order from us get delivery it's
really really good yes very very good
and I'm not I [ __ ] love Joe
sandwiches uh we are open Tuesday
through Sunday come see us and then oh
also bonfire listen bonfire yeah unless
it goes on it all the time I'm on it all
the time yeah and that's it uh Humble
Pie segment ready you ready the winner
with 52 is casseroles
[ __ ]
baked and delicious
just like me that's rematch territory
that's rematch territory so we'll have
you back at some point with Sal and
we'll rematch off air oh God that
[ __ ] garbage you're gonna go
casserole that that garbage guppy bottom
feeder I love them I love them well 100
pick casserole and you know what we'll
do soup over salad that trash I would
too uh and and when Sal and I defeat you
in the rematch I'm gonna bring a lovely
casserole over to his house and we're
gonna eat it while watching wrestling
Dan if there was a lovely casserole it
wasn't made by you I know that much I'll
make about making my mama's lasagna oh
dude how dare you uh all right you have
to close the show by saying I still love
you I still love you I love you too I
love you very much
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them like I'm talking taste buds